last week I had a raging fight with my
flatmate like a screaming match and it
was about a chocolate bar and a salad
bowl and I'm not the only one having
problems the resistance from
illustration is lower for hidden walls
in the long run it's not a healthy way
to coexist I was lashing out on my
husband I would like take it out on
Cameron and we were kind of bickering a
lot being cooped up together means that
the potential for conflict is high very
high you've probably heard about the
divorce numbers spiking in China
self-isolation can lead to challenging
and in some cases extreme situations so
I took two couples and families around
the globe about how they are handling
the situation and I asked a couples
therapist how to best cope with being
boxed in with other people
ona Guralnik is featured in a document
couples therapy
one force that's happening right now is
that we are confronted with differences
like I see couples kind of falling into
very kind of intense fights about
difference and difference in coping
style or difference in view I think
respecting difference respecting
boundaries is key so I'm advising people
to really create very artificial
boundaries and stick to them like
dogmatically like set a timer if you
need to be if you can't literally be in
separate I'm sorry hold on one second
guys that it's for example someone in
truths you say not now told them you
cannot walk in really rigid about it and
rules can be very simple like what my
friends Ellery does we've had to set
some boundaries and we have a rule that
if one person has their headphones in
and that means like don't bother me or
like simple things only if it's an
emergency it does not mean that if you
you know your husband is not spending
time with your wife is not spending time
with you if they don't love you as much
it's just that everyone needs their
space that is if you can get some space
is luxury I'm privileged because I live
in a big apartment with my flatmates but
a lot of people all across the world
don't have that luxury
Meeny they have to be imaginative and
create mental boundaries if you are for
example in a particular mood or you're
struggling with a particular issue it's
very easy to call your partner in to
play a role in your own internal drama
and now it's kind of primetime for those
kind of dynamics so the first week I
felt very cooped up and was very
restless and I would like take it out on
camera and we were kind of Pickering a
lot because I felt super unhappy to kind
of listen to the music of that and not
buy into your own story and kind of pull
back from that and move into like the
melody of like we're in this together I
tried to channel that in a more healthy
way so I've taken up a lot of hobbies I
realized I just need things to occupy my
time I was lashing out on my husband
thankfully some sense to build and now
there's a rhythm to everything that we
are doing but it is also true that
during stressful times underlying
conflicts can boil over and turn violent
domestic violence rates have gone up not
only in China but also in Europe and
elsewhere Rachel Williams is a domestic
abuse survivor herself and the women's
rights campaigner in the UK I can just
put myself back in living with the
domestic terrorists because that's what
they are and you know at least then you
know I could get eight naps and breathe
in space but you know these victims are
survivors now in lockdown so they are in
a prison with a domestic terrorist some
things are going to be heightened to a
massive magnitude if you think perhaps
your neighbor might be experienced
domestic abuse violence next door you
know perhaps going up the door you know
with with the the the the 2 meter
distance in you know and asking is
everything all right 20 victim survivors
watching this at the moment to need help
please make the call you should be
able to dial in and report something
domestic news everybody's business each
country has different help hotlines and
organizations many of which are trying
to ramp up their capacities during the
crisis if calling is too risky you can
also contact many of them digitally but
thankfully this situation could also be
a new opportunity for relationships
I think people also have the capacity to
work through things that otherwise they
wouldn't want to it's a particular
moment in time where we're not embedded
in our everyday lives so we have the
capacity to think bigger
and and to understand things on a bigger
scale this is the reason why it's going
great between us now
yeah because we have time to so I think
that this would be this will help us to
understand each other better yeah I had
I have a situation where on day three of
the congee with my flatmate I got in a
screaming match with him for the first
time in my life
of course oh yeah just predict with you
what happened
you probably had like a screaming
Matthew or each like shocked at the
state you got into and then you came out
of it better than ever
sorry humanity is in a moment where it's
being tested and it's our chance to show
our best selves to each other the option
to go through something together is is
huge being able to see that rather than
just take it for granted is profound I
think we've come closer as our family in
spending so much time with our little
one I think I'm also realizing what I'm
happy with my family like I'm happy that
these are the people of quarantine with
I can't imagine being currently with
anybody office all the time which
questions do you have about your life at
the coroner crisis please let us know in
the comments
[Music]